what has happened in reject nation it is
Greg Alva here
it's Kyla menhir the Kyler men from the
fan Theory Channel is right here with us
today Kyle I met an acting class our
acting teacher
Kimberly Bigsby has a husband who is the
showrunner for this new series is called
Waco they have a trailer out that has
three million views on YouTube right now
we were like well we got to watch this
trailer then yeah to show our support
for Kimberly and her awesome husband
South who I did talk to you once for a
half hour very nice guy yeah super nice
kind of intimidating briefly because of
how talented he is but very nice guy
intimidating but nice let's leave with
that yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
6-part huh you looked me to be your
leader to guide you on this journey
[Music]
but I'm only I'm following just like you
but God has instructed me to stay here
and wait for his son Mac you've been
hurt this is our time to prove through
suffering that we are worthy of a
miracle as the code
[Music]
the kingdom of heaven has come oh man
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey it's John Leguizamo hey click below
to subscribe to the Paramount Network
channel on YouTube for more on wake up
okay thanks John Leguizamo comedian and
for a trailer like this I don't think
you need to reveal a whole lot of
information I mean this event what
happened with like a 93 or something
yeah it was in the 90s like super early
90s and only lasted a few months but it
was a pretty historical event I'm
fascinated by how television is
exploring a lot of this like true crime
oh yeah it sings a song it's a theme
right now yeah it sounds like hotcakes
they say people love the true crime it
looks shot really well and I'm sure
he'll have like a strong level
authenticity to it seems like something
Ryan Murphy would have done well he
probably would have made it a little
more twisty I think yeah fictionalize
I'd imagine yeah this looks like it has
a much more subtle approach to it it
doesn't look as like crazy ridiculously
at least yeah so far yeah that we're
seeing here I'm really impressed with
what I'm seeing so far especially from
Taylor Kitsch because I'm not I'm not
big Taylor Kitsch fan and I just saw an
American assassin and I was like yeah
and that was my takeaway that that you
were just pointed out to is that yeah
they're kitsch was someone when I was
watching do isn't like whoa he actually
gets a chance to really shine in the
performance finally I feel like that's a
lot of the time he doesn't really get
the chance to shine in here this looks
like a performance where he might be the
biggest take away because when I hear
Michael Shannon's in it my main thought
oh yeah oh I want to see Michael Shannon
but this trailer capitalizes on you know
the cult leader David Boreanaz and I
have no idea what the real David Koresh
is like but I believed him and this is
the brief images walk out of him yes
cult leader yeah I met him he was a
really good guy yeah it's not been great
for him it has not been great for him
not since Friday Night Lights yeah yeah
but even I feel like TV's probably the
format yeah cuz he has that look where
he get typecast in a movie yeah
televisions where he gets a chance to
really show
Rane based off like a lot of the
true-crime tales we get I feel like this
is probably gonna have more of a subtle
build to it like a little more dread
filled oh yeah something something
lingering under the surface just enough
to keep the uneasy and I imagine it'll
really creep under your skin yeah I
wonder if we can interview her husband
you should do that I should do that just
have him spoil the entire show oh yeah
Melissa Benoist and Miz and super girls
in here she's gorgeous
I can't wait for people to come out and
start saying how inaccurate some stuff
is and how accurate some stuff is
there's a lot of conspiracy surrounding
this story I mean can you really argue
if it's false unless you were actually
there yes yes you can Google I never do
that you never do I never look up was
she control I never bothered a look of
what was actually wrong that was damn
good television like People vs OJ I was
like this is all true I just believe it
people are gonna do it regardless yeah
doesn't seem to me
well guys are you excited for Waco do
you think this accurately represents
everything that happened during the Waco
events with David Duchovny leading it's
called reject look that notification
bell follow the Cuyler men on Twitter
and Instagram but more importantly check
out his YouTube channel fan theory
there's a link here YouTube will not
automatically unsubscribe you he has
never dealt with that problem and
neither have I go check it out